[Musique]
et qu'un petit bruit ce garçon aux yeux
clairs qui nous l'a emmené m champs et
enfin au cinéma on tenait comme mon papa
tu parles ne va pas plus loin
vas-tu te faire ou la menteuse
garçon n'a rien pour plaire allez
l'amour
metella de vos cheveux blancs la légende
est patent
écoute bien petit frère à jamais une
bonne manière tu es trop jeune encore
des manques tu sais que tu attends mon
nom at elle un sens du palais des papes
à gap nous l'avons fait
nous
petit frère tu te taire ou la rente
[Musique]
même s'il a déjà les yeux vers 26 genre
tu es une année
mamour 11
[Musique]
check
il est gentil
qui la
folie
imaginez que je trouvais le mot d'amour
[Musique]
maxime a beaucoup de charme la fois il
me désole
c'est bien petit ravi
mais je suis simplement dit ce garçon me
plaisait et hier je te le diras captifs
radi
non
en europe on pleure et l'amour
ses cheveux longs matin j'entendais pas
tomber
tu dois t'arrêter un peu mais je n'ai
pas pu payer
n'écoutez jamais
il y avec moi
et
[Musique]
affaires hier
c'est michel drucker
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]